did you ever think you make I tast viory
I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath we got
bet David value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters how run homie
look what I
become okay episode
347 uh uh we haven't uh uh we haven't
done an episode since last Thursday or
Friday it's been a long time it feels
like it's been a couple months feels
like we made it maybe because we're
trying to eventually get to a point to
see if we can do this thing for five
times a week who knows maybe that day
one day will come in24 I'll run out of
shirts and ties so I have a Dre so we
got a lot of stories a lot of crazy
stories a lot of people claiming that
musk has got drug issues that's going on
we'll talk about that and he's
responding to it boing what is going on
with this boing plane everybody sitting
there saying I thought the exit seat was
the best one extra leg room I got to
worry about can you imagine everybody
around the nation is now worried about
the exit
by the way the craziest thing with this
Boeing situation is they haven't been
following the fa FAA guideline for
quality control for the longest time and
eventually whistleblowers at boink told
others that boink doesn't do the FAA
quality control guidelines did you know
this that's pretty crazy so they they
lost $13 billion just yesterday that's
what happens when you do something like
that we got we got a we got a clip from
uh Josh Holley going after FBI director
Ray it's awesome you got to see it we
got another clip with the door on the
plane going we got a couple Haley Clips
Haley's very popular right now and on
her views on parents and then her views
on uh uh pardoning Hunter Biden you know
it's an interesting way she answered it
and then you got a clip that you want to
show from our friend and then Jewish
folks underground New York very
interesting what they're doing in New
York you have to answer for your people
there underground parties aside from
that uh offices around America hit a new
vacancy record new vacancy record barely
third of Americans expect economic
Improvement in
2024 Lululemon hits back chip Olson I
interviewed this guy seven eight years
ago freaking phenomenal guy do you know
this guy the CEO of Lululemon it's worth
nearly 5 six billion do you know he
would go to work on a daily basis in a
speedo that's it and he would walk
around literally this is a true story in
a speedo stud of a guy who was a former
swimmer we'll talk about him okay I
can't wait remind me to bring up
American Peril CEO when we do that so
then Biden apparently according to JP
Morgan they're predicting Biden will
pull out of the presidential race this
is not Fox News this is not CNN this is
not a podcast saying it this is J Morgan
predicting that Biden's going to pull
out the race it doesn't get bigger than
JP morgan7 trillion nearly of money
circulates through JP Morgan on a daily
basis US Supreme Court to hear Donald
Trump's ballot ban we'll talk about that
MSNBC host gets emotional folks if you
haveen seen it get some of the tissue
ready for you because it's it's U you're
not going to show it cuz I I don't think
I could deal with it's it's worse than
you know I'm trying to think about like
most emotional moments of movies
notebook you know it's more emal when
Gladiator when he when uh Maximus sees
his wife is it worse than it's bad Bambi
it's like Bambi level type emotion so
when we do that just skip that part
Vinnie it's not good for you but it's
like the funny part at the end of full
metal dragon got it Democrats question
whether Biden should agree to debate
Trump Watch Dog watch this one folks FKS
finds 81% of all political late night
show jokes in 2023 targeted
conservatives anyone surprised weird
many college grads struggle to land jobs
due to lack of preparedness by the way
kids are showing up after college they
got their four-year degree they shown up
to job interviews with their parents can
you imagine this not uh Larry who are
these people
that so how you how good are you going
to take care of my boy how little Joey
how you going to do with this you we all
know that's how I got this job my mom
showed up she's like listen Mr B David
he's a good boy truth be told his mom
did show up but that was after he got
hired kind of like when she used to drop
you off for summer and then my dad
showed up Tom the biz do El with my step
over here by the way thanks for putting
a good work for Mcafee stood up to ESPN
and flat out called them out good for
because the week prior to that he got he
got shot for apologizing so the week
later named names yeah bill bich and the
New England Patriots are about to get
divorced will they we'll see Tiger Woods
ends a 27-year partnership with Nike
kind of wild we'll talk about that Joe
Koy I don't know if you watched the
monologue I know Joe Koy did you watch
the monologue K be 100 with you no I did
not I Wasing so if you know Joe Coy say
knowing Joe Koy it's the worst monologue
I've ever heard let me say that okay it
was so bad that I had to go watch Ricky
Jes just for me equilibrium for me to be
leveled off the clip it was terrible not
only did Taylor Smith not find it funny
I don't think anybody found it funny but
it is what it is and Ricky's Ricky's
monologue could have been done this year
yeah uh the santis is he going to drop
out of the race on January 15th a lot of
people are saying this this is the hill
by the way I want to talk about that and
he likes the STIs some of those guys
there and then we have AOC gives away
the game on America's Southern border
Crisis crisis in a video uh and then we
got Michelle Obama did a podcast with Mr
J Shetty and she claimed she is
terrified oh no about not the movie FNAF
or It or Leave the World Behind Silence
of the lamps or leave but she's
terrified no about the 2024 election
Vinnie exactly when Pat does that voice
I just get intimidated on him I do too
I'm so nervous never know by the way
before we get started yesterday we had
the sick of strategy session we were
away for the last two days we stayed in
Miami we had a meeting at the one hotel
we had a 14-hour meeting yesterday today
absolutely freaking insane phone set
aside I am so excited about the future
by the way just last week when we
announced the future looks Sprite
initiative with the hats I don't know
how many thousands of hats were picked
up last week some of them are going to
be on back order we're getting some new
ones here the entire premise of this
year I want everybody to confuse the
living crap out of everybody in your
life to sport the future looks bright
gear when you go to work when you go to
your family they say as CRA How are you
so optimistic I'm telling you the future
looks bright you're going to see why
because there's going to be a certain
waking up of certain leaders in in
America and the world we've never seen
before there's a whole initiative on
what we're going to be doing with that
brand with the futur look Sprite being
all over the place I'm excited about
that but anyways before we get into the
podcast with all these stories let's
first go to our sponsors go ahead Rob so
look I've been in the financial industry
since 911 the day before 911 and I've
owned stocks mutual funds real estate
crypto gold you name it I've owned it
but the one thing that's very important
part of my portfolio all these years is
gold I love having a percentage of my
network in Gold that I have access to in
case of many different things that's why
we chose to work with our new sponsor
American Harford gold if you have
retirement funds that you cannot afford
to lose American Harford gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American Harford gold a a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on a link in the
description or call
866939 6984 again
6984 all right let's get right into it
first of all let's give a quick shout
out to Michigan the national champ big
deal for you look my dad went to
Michigan my family's from Michigan my
family's from Detroit I remember growing
up 1997 Charles Woodson everything was
going on there this has been a long time
coming everything all the the disarray
that was going on with Jim harble this
year and the
allegations 15 and0 they beat Ohio State
this year they beat Alabama they beat
the back pack 12 Championship Washington
Tom Brady our boy Tom Brady he's very
happy right now so is Dave portnite by
the way but shout out to Michigan
Wolverines college it great seeing that
it was very good seeing that okay so
let's get right into the stories okay uh
let's start off with a little bit of
economy offices around America hit a new
vacancy record according to Wall Street
Journal and this number is not a number
that's uh something to be bragging about
here we go uh office vacancies in major
US cities have surged to record high
with 19.6% of office space Unleashed in
the fourth quarter up from 18.8 from
previous year this marks the highest
vacancy R since
1979 wow ACC that's 44 years ago 40 yeah
44 years ago 45 years ago according to
Moody's Analytics the overbuilding trend
in the 80s and the early 990s resulted
in a glut of Office Buildings many of
which were constructed in the 50s and
the 80 50s through the 80s currently the
three major US cities with the highest
vacancy rate are Houston Dallas Austin
this is all Texas by the way Texas
shifting War cits include including the
move towards working uh uh open floor
plans and remote work have contributed
to the rise in office vacan vacancies
the covid-19 pandemic accelerated the
shift leading companies to realize they
need less space per employee Tom M wow
wow wow wow wow wow look at this well
first of all 19.6 is a national average
um and so you need to step back from
that like that here in Miami I think the
office vacancy rate in Miami is under 6%
right now um it's very low a lot of
companies and people have moved down
here so if you're in commercial real
estate Miami you probably the issue you
got is probably finding homes for your
clients um Texas the issue I know for
fact is overbuilding they didn't think
they were overbuilding because no
private Equity company or a large
Community Bank is going to say okay
here's a billion dollars to build this
massive office parking garage and
everything goes with it and have no one
there they just got caught out by the
amount of inventory they built which
means if you're thinking of moving to
Texas where there's no state income tax
and there's a lot of other uh lifestyle
things guess what you probably get a
very costeffective um you know uh
building for your for your team there
but the other side of it is San
Francisco which is horribly vacant so
when you see these uh averages folks
always remember these are National
averages and what is the reality is the
that for you as a business is whatever
the reality is in the town where you are
or you're trying to do it and San
Francisco everything's vacant Miami
everything's full and here's a question
Tom beautiful new buildings in Texas if
you're moving there here's a question uh
is this is this a permanent thing is
this a seasonal thing is this something
that's going to change what will change
it are we at a point where you know a
lot of these guys are starting to
realize look maybe the real answer is
the following Tom
20% of America is overbuilt with Office
Buildings for current population Siz
that we have is that the right way of
looking at it meaning at 350 million
people in America 20% of Office
Buildings are too much uh one too many
which means the next time we're going to
need this much office space maybe we'll
be when that 350 becomes 420 so Rob can
you see if there's a mat to say when
will US population hit 420 million but
the opposite argument to that may be by
the time we get to 420 million we're
going to have such great technology AI
that that 20% may go to 30% may go to
40% what do you think is going to be
happening so I think they've built the
wrong the wrong stuff right now we've
got too much commercial space on a
national basis and especially in Texas
and we don't have enough like apartments
condos and things corre that people
could rent and so I look at it and the
question I ask and I'm not going to plug
anybody but there are Venture
capitalists out there and there are
startups out there that are converting
two and three floors at a time of an
office building into basically Studio
Plus Apartments uh they they get a
bathroom in there they get a kitchenet
in there and suddenly for 1,500 bucks
you know a person with a job downtown
you know has everything they need so a
lot of that space needs to be repurposed
and the Venture Capital Community and a
lot of startups are out there saying hey
give me three floors of this building I
will you lease it to me I will convert
it to you know 20 efficien Apartments uh
per floor and they're really nice
Apartments I I toured one I didn't
invest but I uh got involved and I uh uh
with a startup that's in the Dallas area
and they pulled it off and they got
three floors of an office building down
there that is now like 60 Apartments
very interesting so office and apartment
combined I mean they got some of the uh
buildings here like we were we were
going to buy those buildings on the
water on the inter Coastal remember what
they told us they said some 60% has to
be office 40% has to be tenants exactly
right yeah it's similar now not
everybody stays at the Four Season but
if you've ever driven by or seen some of
the Four Seasons a lot of times in major
cities the top five floor the four
seasons are residences and it'll say
that that's the Four Season residences
up here or Mandarin residences that is
an example of the hotel people half of
it hotel and then half of it and then
one third of to me 2/3 is hotel and one/
third is permanent so pbd you asked the
question is this just seasonal is this
sort of temporary let me tell you
something uh this ain't going this ain't
changing the game has changed
dramatically what do I mean well just
like uber did to the car industry just
like A&B Airbnb did to the hotel
industry just like Bitcoin did to just
normal Financial products and fungible
tokens and all that fun stuff just like
podcast did to Media same thing's going
on here with commercial real estate Tom
hit the nail on the head damn right did
you know it but I hit it we supply and
demand we've got too much office space
and not enough homes so what do we mean
we all see what happened during Co we
started using using acronyms like WFA
work from anywhere wfh work from home
covid basically was the Catalyst to what
was already going to happen people were
already working remote these things were
already occurring and then boom covid
Zoom meetings just smack you right in
the face next thing you know you're
working you got your you know your
mullet outfit going on you got you know
business up top Party Down Below you in
your boxer briefs downstairs and if
you're tubing you're masturbating
that but you know what's happening and
Tom sort of alluded to it you're going
to have these basically work where you
live type buildings where people are
having a less kids we know that uh you
don't need to be running around to the
office anymore you know there's this
hybrid work things we obviously know
that you're a big advocate of getting
your ass in the office so am I but most
companies are totally cool with you
working remote especially if you can
find the best talent but it comes down
to supplying demand there's not enough
uh homes out there people want to work
from home there's way too much
commercial uh office space so rents are
going to be a little bit lowered and
that's going to be good for a little
company based in Fort Lauderdale called
value tainment because we're looking for
a h office campus and some of these guys
that are looking to sell their property
are going to need to basically off
they're aggressively aggressively
recruiting us to move to Miami so we're
going to see what's going to happen with
that sounds horrible Pat we don't want
to be living in Miami not what we need
aggressively recruit
move the building to Miami but we'll you
want to make sense of this p on your end
yeah I I I think that's the I'm purely
asking data like when you pulled up the
population we're not going to get to 370
million people but God knows when you
know like 366 most likely by
2100 that's what 76 years from now to
get to 360 where are we right now Rob
335 340 I mean population yeah what's
the US population right now so if we
going to go uh uh okay 331 that's but
that's 2021 so let's say 2024 we're at
340 give or take I don't know I I I
don't know if this yeah 335 in the US I
don't know if this applies to all
Industries I don't know if this applies
to Industries I think it's going to be
pocket I think it's going to be cities I
think it's going to be regulation I
think it's going to be overbuild I think
it's going to be a lot of that stuff and
by the way you know Black Rock right now
is laying off 3% of their employees
that's 600 employees that be laying off
even though their numbers are back up
they're doing okay but you know it it's
going to it's going to be predicated
based on Tom go ahead you're you're
trying to say something he's itch I know
it when he's moving I was I was waiting
for you because there's those three
lines over there on the left are pretty
interesting got it so so one birth every
9 seconds one death every 9 seconds and
one international migrant every 28
seconds then a question you have to ask
on top of all this is where does AI fit
into all this that's the part where does
Ubi fit into this Universal basic what's
going to happen with all that stuff yeah
so again we'll see what's going to
happen there now next one here is
Americans are racking up more Phantom
debt and if you know what Phantom debt
is this whole buy now pay later type of
stuff and that's a problem when you see
how this thing actually uh works so uh
uh Rob run another poll again I'm
curious I know we ran it last time how
many people have used the buy now pay
later system ever just buy now pay lader
ask that question yeah see what people
will tell you there so uh buy not pay
later loans can be challenging to track
have surge in popularity with a 14%
year-over-year increase during the
holidays according to Adobe data this
type of debt often not reported to
Credit Agencies is referred to as
Phantom debt and it could indicate that
total household debt levels are higher
than traditional measures suggest warns
Tim quinland senior Economist at Wells
Fargo managing multiple buying out pay
later loans with different payments
dates is a challenge potentially leading
to increased Consumer Debt uh BM PL
again buy not pay later could lead to an
increase in Consumer Debt as consumers
may be more likely to take additional
debt if they know they can spread out
payments a survey revealed that 42% of
buy our PID later borrowers made late
payments toward those loans Tom Dam well
guess what we remember what happened to
credit card debt it smashed the one
trillion ceiling right at the uh end of
September remember went right back up we
we talked about this at length it got
down a little under half a billion
during covid and all it's over a
trillion so it but we also saw that
wages weren't really up and the the
workforce really didn't grow you know
dramatically so that means those folks
put them in debt for one trillion and
Along Comes bnpl companies saying hey
click here buy now pay later and and um
Pat talked about this on a podcast and
he explained the difference between a
hard inquiry and a soft inquiry so it
was a soft inquiry on People's Credit so
it doesn't show up on the credit report
yet so they got
to find a way to buy whatever it is they
want to buy so they use bnpl where they
break something into like three four
payments and suddenly they're in more
debt than actually their credit report
reveals so B so wait cuz Tom my brain
when you guys talk about money and B and
all that crap so you're saying that
consumers are putting themselves deeper
in the hole so like let's say I want to
max out my credit card but I still want
to buy more stuff I can do and they let
me do it right yeah bmpl you can do it
so it's B so it's byy now poor later
that what I'm going to be broke as
you little I hit that nail in the head
you know the layaway concept the layaway
concept was you didn't get the product
yeah you have to keep paying until you
you have to keep paying until you get
the product which by the way that's
great to have a layway product this is
like layway product but you get what you
want upfront why why would you do that
this is this is like saying you're going
to college but we're going to give you
the four-year degree up front even
though you it's going to take four years
for you to really get it but guess what
for the sake of helping you get a better
job take this forear degree up front we
know later on you're going to get it
what a stupid system right to stupid but
you're hurting people hardcore getting
into more debt as if we're not already
in too much debt you're adding even more
to it and people are using it so they're
they're they're hoping because they're
like okay we'll give it to you they're
hoping you start missing those payments
because the once you miss a payment what
does it jump up to no no it's skyrockets
it's ridiculous by the way no surprise
America's got a trillion dollar credit
card debt and 42% of the buy now pay
later that started on Black Friday um
has been late Oh weird Rob what's the
poll look like what a surprise yeah
weird ladies and gentlemen okay let's go
to the next store here can I just add
one thing um I get a chance to weigh in
on this but we're not going to go to
everybody I don't go to Vinnie every
time but if you have something real
quick go for it well I just what we
realized is that since Co this this
k-shaped economy is a real thing you
know they talk about the difference
between Wall Street and Main Street for
those of us lucky enough to know how
finances work and you've saved that
money you've invested life's great you
know everyone thinks like Vinnie we had
this conversation the other day what do
you think the current inflation rate is
the other day everyone's like 8 12 15
current inflation rate is 3% but there's
a covid hangover so people don't realize
that the economy has gotten better but
for people at the top if you're at the
bottom and you're the two-thirds of
America that's living paycheck to
paycheck you're struggling unemploy
people think that unemployment is a 20%
sorry it's a 3 and a half% so people
think the economy is a lot worse than it
is because those are the people on Main
Street people on Wall Street they're
doing great everyone wants to know hey
there's a recession this year they going
to happen in 2024 now it turns out the
stock market went up 25 freaking percent
meanwhile you have the people living
paycheck to paycheck I just did a video
across the street at this Amscot you
familiar with that yeah where it's the
payday loans where the money people I
went in there I'm like hey if you want
to get your money absolutely wrecked
come visit here us at Amscot they show
you on the signs in the building that
they charge 400% 500% 300% what it is
and people are doing it there's a line
out the door I'm like you guys are
getting your ass kicked by amcot shout
out to amcot right now by the way check
this at 240 branches 2,000 plus
employees has been around since 1989
yeah so it's not like there's not a
business forward there's a business
model for the poor just getting poor and
that's the unfortunate thing and and Pat
you a million times during where do you
think the money flows when you give out
free money and you give out stimulus
checks it's going to flow to the top we
saw who who became the richest man in
the world during covid it wasn't Elon
Musk it was Bernard o no who basically
owns who doesn't basically he owns lvmh
which stands for Louis Vuitton Moet
Hennessy they own everything Gucci Prada
uh Moet this that they own every store
in the mall and this guy became the
richest guy in the world because
everyone got their stimulus checks they
didn't pump it into a Roth IRA they
pumped it into a new bag from Balenciaga
and that's exactly what happened he
looks like Joe Biden's cousin look at
him you know there a very there's we'll
get on the next thing here my Parting
Shot Pat is there's a very interesting
uh rule of thumb that says take all the
stimulus that's given to every household
that's under 100 Grand that's two people
making 50 just take 12% of it and that's
what's and and that's the net gain for
the stock market why it's iida cuz they
spent it all and it ends up on the
bottom line profit for all the companies
on the stock Market that made all the
stuff that they just bought listen let
me let me talk to to you know certain
people here right now so I have I have a
few people that I'm talking to this year
and to the people whose income grows but
you're constantly broke you don't have
an income
problem to the people that you know if
you were broke making 50k a year and you
said if I only make more money I'm G to
be better then you broke at 100K then
you're broke at a quarter million then
you're broke at a half a million then
you're broke at a million you're going
to be broke no matter how much money you
ever make now I'm not talking about the
power of broke like hey it you know
always when you get money let it go out
and all not
chrisn that's like a bad moment you just
had right there but that's
okay in the pursuit of that interview is
like hey Samuel Jackson I'm not Sam you
think just because I'm black I'm Sam
Jackson I'm Lawrence fish anyways so if
you're constantly making that increasing
your income but you don't have savings
there's a
problem at whatever level I I posted
something on Twitter just a minute ago
Rob if you want to go pull this up I
literally posted this morning and I said
everyone has a reputation if you just
click on that and zoom in a little bit
cuz yeah there you go uh go a little bit
I said everyone has a reputation some
good some bad your actions determine
your reputation in the marketplace New
Year's Eve 2002 I'm at In-N-Out Burger
in University Studios literally in the
backside with another guy that we split
the uh In-N-Out burger and we got water
with lemon and sweeten loaf you know why
because that's called lemonade and we
split it split the double double he gets
one he gets half I get half and what's
the Ryan C Chris is doing to 10987654321
yeah then I'm sitting there saying what
a freaking shitty way to go into a new
year okay going through a bad breakup I
got not a penny to my name I'm $49,000
in debt life sucks I'm asking God I'm
talking to myself do I go back and join
the Army is that what I do do I just go
back and do 20 years because I've
already done two and a half years with a
little bit of Reserve which means I got
probably five years I only need to do 15
more years what do I do there and then I
made in my mind I'm like what's your
reputation cuz my dad would say you're
this your dad you're I made a list of
reputation that I had in the marketplace
out of everything I wrote down I wanted
my new reputation to be and it came down
to one thing I wanted the new reputation
to be whatever Pat says he's going to do
it's going to get done I wanted my word
to cash my big many big checks and it
was going to take a bold new reputation
I wanted to bring confidence in the
people who believed in me and put the
fear of God in those who didn't I know
it sounds a bit dark but that's me it
was the hardest reputation to build
because the pressure that it comes with
but just like shooting free throws the
percentage of things getting done kept
increasing higher and higher and higher
we have a big Vision with a ton of work
today but the reputation getting things
done got started back in 2002 if you
allow a reputation to linger around it
eventually becomes a permanent
reputation you know your reputation you
know who you are no matter how much you
make yourself feel good about your
reputation your actions have caused you
the reputation that you currently have
today but you can choose to change that
now never let the world dictate your
reputation if you do they'll own you
forever future looks bright what's the
point here I don't how much money you
make start saving money you're going out
to the party I'm not coming we're going
out to the club Saturday night dude I'm
not coming we're going to go over dude
I'm not coming we're going to go do this
I'm not coming save save invest save
save save your income goes up don't
change your lifestyle your income goes
up don't change your lifestyle your
income goes up don't change your
lifestyle let your income increase two
three four five times before you
dramatically change your lifestyle mhm
if you can afford to live in a million
doll home live in a half a million doll
home if you can afford to live in a $3
million home live in a million doll home
if you can afford to live in a $1
million home live in a $2 million home
and then all of a sudden boom you're
like man this pillow got softer I sleep
better right now I feel better what the
hell just happen all of a sudden because
you made better decisions so some people
have an income problem fine but most
people don't have an income problem most
people have a saving and a spending
problem that's haunting them and when
you are in debt and you're owing
everybody money you just you are just
not in a good you're in a weak place you
don't do husband better you don't do
friend better you don't do business
better you don't do any of that stuff
better so that's my biggest thing when
we're talking about buying out pay later
don't fall for all these
gimmick traps that all these other guys
are selling you just because everybody
else is doing bmpl whatever it's called
you don't need to fall for that trap you
go increase your market value think
about your vision long term what you
want your life to look like what you
want your dreams to look like and then
make better DEC decisions one day you'll
wake up and everyone's going to say wait
a minute what happened to you bro how
are you living this life bro because all
those 97 times you invited me to go
smoke weed and party and do all that
I said no to you that's what
happened and you went okay it's that
simple so we have we just have to make
better decisions and not fall for this
crap when I see this number here 3,400
people voted 28% did a buy out pay later
what's 28% on 3400 that's about a th000
people right give or take have done bmpl
make it decision guys don't do it do not
fall for it anyways let's go to the next
story Lululemon hits back at
founder anti- Dei comments Lululemon
hits back at the founders anti-de
comments they do not reflect our
company's views look at this company
they do not reflect our company's views
you are your Founders company what do
you mean they do not reflect our
company's views your founder started
your company can you imagine how dumb it
is for you to say what you do you
understand what they're saying of course
Lululemon hits back at the founder if it
wasn't for the founder there is no
Lululemon you you know yeah it's
basically what's happening in America
today we don't endorse what our founding
fathers of America basically tried to
make America they were here way before
you and I were here America Matters way
more than you and I do they start this
great country Lululemon distance itself
from its founder chip Wilson's recent
criticism of the company's diversity and
inclusion efforts Wilson has stated
they're trying to become like the Gap
everything to everybody you've got to be
clear that you don't want certain
customers coming in what a powerful
statement the company issued a statement
clar find that Wilson's comments do not
represent Lululemon's views or beliefs
they highlighted that Wilson had no
involvement with the company since his
resignation from the board in 2015
Wilson known for previous controversial
remarks also criticized some of the
models used in Lululemon's advertising
campaigns as sickly unhealthy and not
inspirational according to Forbes look
as they always say you try to please
everybody you please nobody and this is
exactly what's happening here it's so
upsetting you're founder of multiple
companies pbd it must be so upsetting
for the founder of a company the vision
that they have the vision that they cast
the belief that they have the company
they found and then a decade or two
later completely see it crumble totally
endorse what chip Wilson is saying on
this one and he brings up the Gap he
brings up companies that have just
basically tried to basically make it the
what B body positivity Movement we see
what's going on at Victoria's Secret it
used to be known as if you're the most
gorgeous beautiful fit like cream of the
crop woman out there you'll get some
angels on your back right now it's like
yeah if you're looking like Amy Schumer
and you do your thing out there you know
about this V it's like yeah we'll throw
some uh mud colored Angels uh Wings on
you and we'll just uh you roll around
like a little pig out there if you're
lizo out there hey looking good you can
endorse our product the I'm assuming the
whole premise of Lulu Lululemon was
basically look good feel good be fit be
athletic get your ass out there work out
be comfortable do your thing but now
it's turned into basically a Dei
prerequisite where if you're fat you
know you're you're going to make it in
this company this is not the yeah
exactly this is not the first founder
that looks back on a company he made and
watches them deteriorate and has
something to say about it I seem to
recall that Steve Jobs returned to Apple
after they had their 40 years in the
desert and Howard Schultz returned to
Starbucks you know maybe chip needs to
return and by the way the things the
comments he made about models was you
have to remember fashion is incredibly
woke industry and it's an incredibly
drug addled industry yes I said it but
it's true and they're talking about
these size one uh models that are on the
cocaine and diet coke diet and he was
saying they look sickly they don't look
healthy this is not good but some
between that and all this body
positivity stuff and so he's out there
talking would they rather have the CEO
of American Apparel that that CEO who
would use drugs in the office and it was
just a free-for-all of sort of an orgy
of wokeness and he would walk across the
office Stark naked except for a sock
covering Mr Johnson and friends and and
so Tom I have nowhere no clue where this
place is going
can I tell you would you like that can I
tell you who this guy is let me tell who
this guy is first of all Chelson is a
badass he's a BMF I interviewed this guy
many years ago and I intentionally wrote
I think I wore ripped jeans like
literally ripped black jeans because in
his book that I just come out we met in
zuma I don't know where we met it was a
great conversation we had because
apparently he used to go to work in
Speedos okay and the way he started
Lululemon very very what what am I
wearing in this interview yeah yeah
there you go cuz I was telling him a
joke when would you ever see me wear
something like that that is not your
look I don't know where that came from
he and I were and you have to watch an
interview to know what I'm doing but
this guy when we sat down and we spoke
so he do you know how he starts the
company he goes to all the uh local uh
yoga stores in Santa Monica in LA and he
listens to girls complaints after yoga
okay so he realizes the biggest
complaint girls had after yoga is they
couldn't go from yoga to the mall they
had to go yoga coffee home to change
because they were embarrassed and he
talks about the fact that he was worried
it's going to show their uh uh what's
the word no no no there's a word that
they camelto Camelo yeah no literally he
talks about that in the book okay so
he's like well that's a problem and he
says I noticed everybody was saying this
okay so he said I'm going to be able to
fix this he says so I went back and I
designed them and I kept looking at the
girls putting it on and said boom you
can't see it anymore would you be
comfortable going in the mall perfect he
creates that product okay at the time uh
100% of his customers were women then he
goes to 88% of his customers being women
the name he comes up with he says the
reason why I chose the name L because I
noticed Japanese people couldn't
pronounce the word L and it was a joke
to him this guy's a little bit of a joke
prankster type of a guy just so you know
that he said so here's a story by him if
you go to eight outrageous remarks by
Lulu Lemon founder chip Wilson this is
our kind of a guy by the way where's he
from I don't know where he's from but
dude I was with him his family his
family was there they were all laughing
having a good time you could tell this
guy enjoys his life F guy okay so let me
read this to you Wilson once claimed
that smoking and birth control pills led
to high divorce rates okay so that
pissed a lot of people off two he once
said uh he chose to call his company
Lululemon because he thought it was
funny that Japanese people couldn't
pronounce the letter
L he said it was so funny to watch them
try to say it he says because of that I
name my company Lulu Wilson is an avid
fan of a rant and stated printing the
phrase who is John G on the company's
bags in November of 2011 without his CEO
knowing about it like this is that guy
okay so then he takes the company
realizes most of them are uh women you
know what he ends up doing can you type
in right now Lulu what percentage of
Lululemon customers are women versus men
okay I want to say the number he brought
down from 100% to 88% to today's like
1/3 23 yeah check that out a third of
the customer are men in those would you
have ever thought thought about it no
think about when you think about
Lululemon you don't think about women
right you don't think about men you
think about women a third of his
customers in 2020 let alone today so
these guys were able to get both men and
women there's a reason why he's worth $7
billion this guy's a badass guy respect
to chip we need more chips in America to
create jobs a behemoth of a company he
built and he's worth $7 billion and
these clowns are saying our Founders
comments doesn't what we stand for as a
company let me get this straight he gave
the company the name he came up with the
ideas for women for yoga he did all that
stuff and
you don't value what the founder said
you know how comical and foolish this
sounds this is this is the same exact
thing where these magazines like Forbes
that were once the best magazine for
every capitalist in America now the
writers are a Columbia grad journalist
liberal left canat and
capitalist can't stand business people
is not telling business people how bad
capitalist is how bad these money people
are that's what happens to the brand
eventually and loses its control
hopefully that doesn't happen to
Lululemon but all I'm saying right now
if you've never met this man if you've
never spent time with this man go study
his book study him he's an absolute stud
of a guy on how he built this incredible
brand and I hope they don't ruin this
incredible brand chip Wilson build out
there anyways let's go to the next story
good for chip by the way we need more
chips in the
world okay next which one do you want to
let's go to ilam musk and drugs here we
go I don't know what that transition is
but that's what we're going right now
that's what people want to talk about
here we go Elon Musk has used illegal
drugs uh warrian leaders at Tesla and
SpaceX this is a Wall Street Journal
story um Elon mus musk's alleged illegal
drug use includes includes uh what is it
LSD cocaine ecstasy and ketamine often
at private parties with non-disclosure
agreements he had has even taken illegal
drugs with current SpaceX and former
Tesla board memb Steve jeson uh musk's
drug use raises concerns about violating
Federal policies potentially
jeopardizing spacex's government
contracts and breaking company policies
at both SpaceX and Tesla some Tesla
board members have discussed their
worries about his drug consumption uh
informally and his actions have
previously led to an investigation while
some speculate that musk's unusual
behavior could be linked to drug use
others attributed to factors like his
consistent lack of sleep and mental
health challenges Vinnie okay for let's
just take a step back okay always look
at those words allegedly okay and this
is another hit piece just like they
tried with the him being anti-semetic
just about him back in the day with old
women it's it's it's long story short
they're trying to destroy him because he
bought the only Forum that we could have
free speech and you know what let's be
honest you know why he's a huge threat
what year is this year this is election
election year so guess what think about
it last presidential election who who
owned Twitter who was it Jack dorsy
right and what happened 80 FBI agents
were at Twitter stopping every story
that you guys were supposed to hear the
hunter Biden all the all that Twitter
files tw Twitter files so and they they
stopped all these negative stories now
you have Elon Musk who's really
concerned about the open border
situation I don't know if you guys have
been paying attention that's the
majority of Elon must tweets and I me
besides calling Mark Cuban racist he
said yesterday in this tweet this is uh
this is Elon in the USA you don't need a
governmen issued ID to vote and you can
mail in your ballot that's insane okay
think about his reach Patrick I don't
know how many uh millions and millions
yesterday was at 12 million but he just
posted it if that word gets out that
they're cheating okay they're concerned
because he's giving us the platform so
we could talk and point out that
the border is completely wide open okay
there's 12 I think by the end of Biden's
run it's going to be over 12 million
people did you know that and he's saying
that's more than the last three
presidencies uh combined of of
immigration so you think about it and
and mind you P it's not like oh where's
it at 38 38 million almost 39 million
people are seeing this okay then think
about think about how this goes down
then you see people like AOC okay that
complet she's on The Daily Show
which is basically unwatchable unfunny
it's it's the worst show you know what
she's saying with the with the the
solving to this whole just document them
yeah she goes not the wall just let
everybody in but document them do you
have that clip Rob cuz I I want to show
you like I want to show you two things
look look listen to what she says ready
for this listen to this this is this is
who this is this ALC talking about the
Border back up a little bit go here we
go from all parts of the political
Spectrum one of the biggest issues that
we have when it comes to immigration is
the fact that we have an undocumented
population now you can fix that by
trying to build a wall or you can fix
that by trying to document people and
create a path to
citizenship and
um we'll have folks that might say look
at these systems you know that our
shelter system has weight and things
like that but one of the reasons that
our public systems experience weight is
because people don't have you know two
two scary things I want everybody out
there to be concerned about she's the
future she's the future of the
democratic party cuz she people will
vote for her to be president the second
thing that really scares me did you hear
that audience response that audience
clapped yeah but it's The Daily Show No
100% 100% but you know what I think you
know the FBI went after everybody at
January 6 to put them in jail we should
find out everybody in the audience that
was applauding this and for find like
make sure that they don't procreate
including her cuz we don't need that
crap bro and P this goes way back Adam
cuz I know you want to say something
this goes way back this has been their
plan forever Rob I slacked you this clip
of Joe Biden on the Congress floor this
has been a plan with mayorcas next to
him that little rat and this is their
goal of making us non like watch play
play this clip listen an unrelenting
stream of immigration unrelenting
nonstop yeah it's happening you piece of
look folks like me who were
Caucasian of European descent for the
first time in 2017 will be in an
absolute minority uned States of America
look at that rat absolute minority fewer
than 50% of the people in America from
then and on it's a plan will be white
European stock yeah that's not a bad
thing yeah that's a that's a source of
our strength yeah so so think about this
Elon he's he does this with women he's
allegedly doing drugs he hates Jewish
people anything to knock him down to get
rid of him because he's letting us see
like this on xat 1,000% he's the
threat Tom what do you think I mean guys
I I get what you're saying and by the
way for AOC oh it's a brilliant strategy
for the left what they're doing you got
to give them credit on how awesome of a
strategy it is to let this many people
come in more in one Administration than
the last three combined and then you
convert them and give them a path to
citizenship and you know 65% of them are
voting to the left so if you're a
Gambling Man the house is on you are the
house you're winning you know your odds
of winning that bet is on you yeah than
the other side right but go back to the
Elam musk story okay on theam mus story
this isn't some you know Daily Mail or
this isn't some you know Media Matters
that're just this is a Wall Street
Journal and by the way when they
interview the person they're like you
can't write some says listen our sources
are are very credible that this is
actually happening this is not like
we're winging it here and then they
asked the lady from Wall Street Journal
and they said so um you know what does
this mean when it comes out to Tesla
guidelines drugs he says well Tesla has
guidelines that you can't be using drugs
a lot of these companies that he works
for do the same things apply to him it
does and then how about the contracts
that you're getting from you know NASA
and the government contracts all this
stuff same exact thing so now elan's to
Alan's defense he's coming out saying
I've been drug tested every single time
since you know uh what do you call it
the the the Rogan podcast when he did
and you know they've been drug testing
them drug testing them drug testing them
so you know is it true or not Tom what
do you think when you hear a story like
this you've spent some time with some of
these folks you know creative folks in
Silicon Valley that you know they feel
maybe there's an edge when you're taking
this you know Steve Jobs has made
certain comments about LSD what are your
thoughts about The credibility of this
story yeah first of all I think the
story is credible um has Elon Musk used
yeah we saw him smoked dope on um on
Rogan and there's a lot of people
including Elon who are from time to time
have made comments about uh magic
mushrooms or micro doing that is all
over Silicon Valley uh micro doing and
and mushrooms very it's it's it's not
used by everyone but it's widely used so
that doesn't surprise me there and it
doesn't surprised me that that he's
there um and that he's part of it now
some of these other stories here these
these comments from people go back
several years because it does appear
that what elon's drawing a line in the
sand on is hey I just now got tested
I've been tested regularly since 2018 so
you know he's drawing a line there and
so I I think that yeah do I think he's
micro doing using magic mushrooms yeah
yes I do you know and I think the story
is credible do I think he's he's still
um you know binging on the weekend doing
10 rails of 10 rails white magic no no
Tom I want to party you back with you
back in the 80s when you were doing your
thing but but Tom here's my thing here
here's my thing he could micro I don't
give two if he's giving us a
platform to talk if he's putting
into outer space if he's doing neural
link and trying to help people if he's
speaking about the B I get what you're
saying no I get what you're is the
timing no weird to you no bro like but
but you have to know that when you're
when you're that in
your for example like you
know um you know if the profile of an
Elon Musk okay is
anti-authority don't tell me what to do
I'm going to you you can't tell the
profile of an Elon Musk what to do you
can't do it however the the good and the
Bad and the Ugly comes with it because
if he says he's going to do something
he's going to do it if he's got a real
enemy enemy you don't need to worry
about him destroying his enemy he's
going to destroy his enemy because no
one's more obsessed about it than him
but at the same time even a guy at that
level you need to have certain people
behind closed doors that you trust 100%
that nothing even you tell them leaks to
their wife leaks to their husbands leaks
to their friends nothing to say hey man
what do you think about this here's what
I'm thinking about what your thoughts on
this and it's like look
bro just pump the brakes you're a Target
now and here's what could happen to you
and this is what you got to be thinking
about and your enemy the state number
one now he is number one I think so
there's no I don't think there's anybody
and by the way I'm telling you today
he's above Trump and why why why do you
why do you think that why why do you say
that because he has more power today
than Trump does today today he's ahead
of trump when we did our top media you
know ranking for vitim and Rob if you
can pull it up we put a top 50 most
influential media names in media right
yeah if you type in you'll see value
tment this one right here if you guys
haven't gone through this list and we
went from and by the way it was some of
the names we had on the list people are
like wow what AM media to me doesn't
mean you're going to like them or
disagree with them I think we start off
with number 50 being and keep going
through it I think it's Kom 50 and then
it goes all the way down and you can see
all these names that we have look at the
names we got left right center it
doesn't matter you hate you love it's
going to be there right but go all the
way down to number one go all the way if
somebody wants to see it right you can
put the link in the comment section and
chat for them to see it yeah is number
one yeah ahead of trump today okay so
when you are enemy the state number one
you have targets you have threats you
have more cameras all eyes on you and
they're just looking at something so
imagine if a judge is able to use this
and go to SEC and say you are no longer
uh capable of being the CEO and the
chairman of the board of X now who loses
you lose mhm you mhm you don't want that
and so the same guidelines that apply to
an employee at T at Tesla at SpaceX
applies to the founder because you're an
employee yeah you may I may be the
founder I'm still an employee so those
guidelines don't get somebody to say
well you can't get away with it because
it doesn't do that so I'm just talking
like a board member is what I'm talking
about and the mindset of a a Founder
that doesn't like Authority telling them
what to do I'm just you have to be a
little bit careful cuz you're extra
extra targeted I understand that but my
point is though it's I understand I
agree 100% what I'm saying is look at
all the stories that are coming out and
the timing of it he 100% going to get
more 100% it's going to be worse but I'm
saying though I I go back to to the why
and the why is and you nailed it it's
because he's such a threat cuz he's
letting us speak he's letting us see the
stories and you nailed it he is a he is
a don't give them don't give them
another they're going to already make a
bunch of up about you they're
already going to defame you they're
already going to do character
assassination they already hate you yes
don't give them additional ammunition
but where' they get the drug thing from
that's an alleged story but just because
it's credible because it's Washington
Post they're all owned by the same crew
look here's the reality I I I think
you're spot on he is Public Enemy Number
One why above Trump why Trump's got
maybe four to eight more years of really
doing his thing yeah really maybe four
this guy's got four more decades
of doing his thing especially if we end
up on Mars doing our thing so no doubt
that I think Elon should be number one
and just think how weird we are in
America right now four years ago he
voted for Biden yeah fact okay or if not
he definitely endorsed that message it
just shows how far left the left has
gone whereas the right with the
exception of a few people has kind of
maintained their position yeah so just
to show where Elon Musk is where Rogan
is where even Bill Mah is these days
they're just basically dude I might not
be a magga extremist but I certainly ate
this woke mind virus that's going on
here on the left back to the drug thing
so they're accusing him of doing drugs
they're saying he's doing illegal drugs
whether it's ketamine whether it's LSD
whether it's uh cocaine with ecstasy you
know what probably did a little bit of
that I'm sure you know so is that the
biggest deal in the world the under the
influence Trace Amounts of this listen
everyone that goes to Art basil they're
handing out magic mushrooms like it's
basically Hot Cakes going on over there
is it concerning not to me because
there's a difference between
recreational drugs and actually being an
addict okay the look to be clear if
doing drugs recreationally made you the
richest man in the world sign me up for
elon's plan and you know who agrees I
did polls over the week on this exact
same story you know how hard it is to
get anything 6040 everything's so
divisive these days I said what are your
thoughts on Elon Musk doing drugs and I
gave two options let Elon be Elon or
shame on you Elon what do you think the
results were 93% of people said let Elon
do do Elon I also asked what are your
thoughts on the whole woke mind virus
that he's basically going in on
93% of people it was on Instagram 93% of
people said it's a woke mind virus
that's what's going on there so listen
sometimes when you want to dream big and
you want to go to Mars you might need a
little DMT in your life
okay I mean Drogan talks about it
theovon talks about it if Elon Musk
wants to smoke a joint or take a magic
mushroom to relax I'd rather him do that
than just start binge drinking alcohol
and I think the left needs to to decide
which way do you guys want it you want
to decriminalize all drugs you want to
make them legal you Portland Oregon all
the things that they accuse them of
using is legal so he could have said
well I was in Portland for the weekend
you know and and it's legal and or you
know you you know marij Marana should be
legal everywhere and cocaine should be
decriminalized everywhere and mushrooms
and LSD should be legal everywhere which
way do you want it do you want it for a
convenient attack on a guy who's going
to enable the greatest platform for free
speech that we still have used to be the
US Constitution now it's X or do you
want to pick on the guy and say oh oh
drug use drug bad drug bad which way do
you want it but the way that they
categorize drugs is actually very weird
okay there's a big difference to taking
like a micro do of mushrooms then full
on going balls deep in some heroin or
some meth a big difference I I don't
believe none of it you may me see I'm
not going to front you made me see clar
he is the number one threat and it's
because dude the buying Twitter and
making it X is the worst thing that cuz
now we get to talk and see their
and think about what's bigger
Twitter X or truth social final final
Point option one Elon Musk micro doing
doing a few things successfully running
a bunch of companies improving Free
Speech doing a lot for mankind okay
recreational drug user okay very
creative okay whatever fine this is
option one option number two Hunter
Biden
yes untreatable addict with his second
set of teeth pictures of unmentionables
this is an uncontrolled person who's an
addict great Point Tom there's a big
difference between the type of drug that
you're doing no doubt all right let's go
to the next let's go to the next one
here boing imagine folks you're on a
flight and this happens to you Rob if
you want to pull up this video you're on
a flight minding your own business maybe
you're watching a movie maybe you're
chilling maybe you're doing what you're
doing you're reading the book and then
all of a sudden go Ahad and play this
clip boom this is what happens oh you're
on a flight guys look how calm everybody
it's gone that's a full-on flight oh and
Alaska Airlines flight and that door is
is gone it ripped and nobody go ahead
let me let me let me read I got to hear
this let me read this let me read the
story and then I'm sure we'll get into
it so boing 737 airliner grounded by fa
after window blown out in midair whr uh
the Federal Aviation Administration fa
has ordered the temporary grounding of
the 171 boing 737 Max 9 aircraft after a
window has ripped from a plane
mid-flight with some planes requiring
immediate inspections before they can
return to flights and Alaska Airlines
flight and experienced a horrifying
incident as a portion of the plan's fuel
uh uh fuse sled uh blew out midair uh
leading to an emergency landing stunned
passengers described seeing a large
section of the plane blown out with
photos showing a gapping hole in the
aircraft side boing 737 Max planes once
grounded due to safety concerns in 2019
are now facing renewed scrutiny the
recent incident and grounding comes
after the planes were allowed to resume
commercial service in 2020 following
software upgrades and fixes to address
previous safety by the way just so you
know when you look at the story they
lost $13 billion yesterday rumors came
out from whistleblowers that boing no
longer does the same quality control
that they used to and they went hiring
lobbyists to say we are not uh we don't
need to be held to the same standards of
quality control as other companies are
whistleblowers came out talking about
the fact that they no longer check the
whistleblowing they no longer check the
stuff on Boeing planes that they did
before the other day man is minding his
own business he notices a big ass Bolt
from a plane falls into his house did
you see this clip this video they talked
about could have killed could have
killed somebody that's like a bullet
coming down right so I I think FAA is
investigating at because they're
producing so many planes and it's just
like look get it out get it out get it
out get it out quickly quickly quickly
quickly and when you're forced to hit
the planes fast and you're not Q seeing
one two Two bows not being there that's
by the way look at that that came
through his I don't know if that's the
one or not I'll find it and I'll send it
to you but a bol purely boom came and
fell on a plane but go ahead Adam yeah
everyone's trying to figure out what you
know since you wrote the book what their
enemies are I'm still trying to figure
out mine the top of my list is just
sloppiness and cutting corners and
trying to think you can get rich quick
and all that nonsense that doesn't
actually mean putting in the work okay I
this is just sloppy this is scary and
I'm going to take a different angle with
this you know what I blame this on this
is weird Dei because everyone talked
about all right look you know United
Airlines they're at the Forefront of the
story right here we're going to hire all
50% of all Pilots are going to be men
50% of Pilots are going to be all women
uh not so fast guys turns out that 90%
of Pilots are men are you just going to
start casually giving women jobs in the
cockpit there's other things they could
be doing with the cockpit but that ain't
the job that's not the job that ain't
the job Vinnie but this to me is a
trickle down effect of Dei is I hire
this person we we talked about in the
S&P 100 that America 60% white yet they
only hired 6% of white people for the
top positions this ain't a race thing
this is a meritocracy thing get the best
people for the job get the best people
to fly the plane get the best people to
build the plane get the People Best
people to work the plane enough with the
Dei nonsense we've see how basically the
the Sham that that is and this to me is
just a small story about not doing the
best and just kind of doing some
patchwor BS and can you imag so
apparently uh my brother's wife Bianca
was like Vinnie the flight was
completely full that seat was the only
seat that nobody was sitting in what if
God forbid cuz bro when when it's up
there reach ma maximum altitude I don't
got my seat Bel on the moment we reach
you know like 2,000 ft my seat belt's
off could you imagine God forbid you get
sucked out or your kid's on your lap and
you're like just because some guy's like
nah no you know you saw the kid that was
sitting there his shirt got sucked
sucked and thank God he had his seat
belt on and shout out to everybody on
that flight did you see how calm they
were I would have been screaming like a
child if the door I would have been like
the whole flight I would have been
losing my they escaped great Point
Vin an absolute disaster could you
imagine if just one person fell out of
the bank oh my God one you should be
counting your looking blessings it was a
kid shirt oh imagine on a flight cuz I
think it was from like Oregon to
California or Vancouver to the pafic
norest a hawaian Airlines flight where a
a had a structural failure like that and
the flight attendant was standing in the
aisle and she went right out that's a
separate story from this separate this
week as well I'm saying there was a
midair this goes back years and years
and years ago no I'm talking about this
story imagine falling out and landing on
your house Tom it's wild man they they
they escaped a unmitigated disaster oh
my God yeah never found her never yeah
good time what were we gonna say no it's
an you know this is this is just shame
on Boeing I mean the reason they were
grounded in 2019 because the Bowen 737
Boeing 737 Max had Ai and highly
automated um airflight Control Systems
also known as autopilot well this the
sensors that they built into the plane
and the software they built actually
started fighting with each other and in
Africa the plane is saying I think I'm
in the wrong position adjust and then
the plane senses it no go the other way
no go the other way and it created
literally an argument oh you know
between the um the actual physical
sensors and the software and it started
purposing and it fell out of the sky one
was in um Africa I believe but that's
the two 737 Maxes that they had all the
sophistic ated software and there were
whistleblowers at that time that said
here it comes we didn't test properly
yeah Ethiopian Airlines brand new 737
Max 157 people the thing starts
purposing and The Whistleblower said we
did not test this fully this this
software is not tested number one number
two we didn't do the full pilot training
on this because you can turn it off and
you can do workarounds if the plan's in
trouble or heavy weather and the
Ethiopian Pilots didn't know they didn't
know the workaround these aren't these
aren't dumb these are highly skilled
fully educated licensed Pilots then
Boeing so they said didn't have training
systems didn't have workaround systems
and they rushed the thing out out to
Market and then two weeks later either
this was the first one or second one but
there was two of them two of them
crashed for the same reason within two
weeks until globally everyone said okay
stop stop stop stop stop all 737 Maxes
stay where you are nothing's taken off
anymore and you know what they sorry and
guess what it was the same thing quality
control lobbying the fa
cutting the corners and then
whistleblowers coming out we knew it we
were just rushing to Market we knew it
it's the same thing they're saying how
about the fact that nobody's talking
about there was a flight in 2014 I
believe in Malaysia Flight
370 missing disappeared just
disappears nothing to see here no block
box where did it go nobody knows any
answers we haven't solved it who made
that plane can we pull that up Rob we
found one piece airpl aircraft type oh
that was a Boeing yeah they dude what
the hell's going on at Boeing now if you
tell me that Boeing built a plane that
accidentally fell out of the sky from
the Vagner group prian I'm never flying
a Boeing jet again well we all know that
was Putin so we won't go there yeah
whatever but guys th this is scary stuff
man because the number one thing because
I know how much you love Heights Pat
it's your favorite thing ever you love
being up there it's your thing this is
scary stuff cuz you have zero control
like Jesus Take the Wheel literally hate
it and you have no control of what's
going on up there and we're relying on
you Boeing on you the airlines that have
your together but we're starting to
see cracks in the armor of what you're
doing out there and it's scary as hell
or in the uh fuselage yes cracks in
fuselage yeah well look I never want to
hear that word fuselage cuz anytime you
hear the word fuselage there's some
there's some happening you're going
to think twice when the steart next to
all of you sitting in the sudden exit
row here we go Pat McAfee accuses ESPN
by the way you know the whole I think
with uh Mark cubin and Elon Musk going
through it yesterday Elon Musk called
Mark cubin a racist yesterday did you
see that I saw that in between all the
bers back and forth back and forth back
and forth and I proposed I said uh Mark
you're not letting go of this Mark and I
had a very friendly uh uh Twitter
exchange uh on DM each other I would say
probably a hundred messages over a span
of two hours back and forth it was a
debate it was a very U friendly debate
but it was a fiery one that we had I
said listen
I said here's a suggestion for you mark
cubin since you're so confident in your
di argument why don't you do an xace
with Elam musk and others you bring
three to five influencers who agree with
you including bring Tony fouchi if you
want bring whoever you want so you won't
feel like it's one-sided who would like
to see this I would love and and then I
posted a picture below of the Guardian
just to remind him go a little lower the
Dallas Mavericks are consistently the
Wiest team in a black League 15 out of
21 years did he respond to that no he
has he hasn't responded to that he
responded to
but he didn't respond to that on public
and he and I spoke about it so I'd love
to see a Twitter space with Mar cubin on
the and uh
uh talk about that later little feel
like got something to say Pat McAfee
accuses ESPN executive of sabotaging his
show here we go Pat this is what happens
when you go to a company like
Disney a ESPN you are dealing with the
eii scores that you got to be careful
with Pat MAV the Sports Talk sensation
known for his YouTube show has accused
ESPN executive Norby Williamson of
purposefully undermining his show by
leaking false information to the media
McAfee
specifically uh pointed to Williamson as
the one trying to sabotage the program
stating more specifically I believe
Norby Williamson is the guy who is
attempting to sa do you have this clip
WP is attempting to sabotage our program
mcafe you was known for his outspoken
and sometimes controversial style
recently faced
backlash with a guest Aaron roders made
controversial comments related to Jimmy
Kimmel and Jeffrey Epstein McAfee later
apologized for the incident additionally
concerns arose about McAfee's TV ratings
being lower than his lead in raising
questions about the reported $85 million
contract ESPN has with them so think of
about the games they're playing their Ro
if you have that clip go ahead and play
it I don't know if this is it we're very
appreciative and we understand that more
people are watching the show than ever
before we're very thankful for the ESPN
folks being very hospitable now there
are some people actively trying to
sabotage us from within ESPN more
specifically I believe Norby Williamson
is the guy who is attempting to sabotage
our program I'm not 100% sure that is
just seemingly the only human that has
information and then somehow that
information gets leaked and it's wrong
and then it sets A Narrative of what our
show is and then are we just going to
combat that from a rat every single time
I don't know but like somebody tried to
get ahead of our actual ratings released
with wrong numbers 12 hours beforehand
that's a sabotage attempt and it's been
happening basically this entire season
from some people who didn't necessarily
love the old addition of the pat mcy
show to the ESPN family sure there's a
lot of those we've heard them
anonymously quoted in the Washington
Post in the New York Post in the New
York Times in the LA Times in Wall
Street Journal and they never like yeah
love the show this is awesome it's
always like little things to try to tear
us down so even with the Enemy Within
our own Camp somebody that we don't I
don't like that I that guy left me in
his office for 45 minutes no showed me
in 2018 so this guy has had zero respect
for me and in return same thing back to
him for a long time so even with that
taking place and potential PR like
there's we're still growing somehow
yep I love it pat
mcafe my question to you is though as a
business guy so you think cuz I don't
know you think it's smart for him to air
out one is that guy a producer the the
the guy he's talking about he's an
executive is that is that smart to do
that to him about here's what I'll say
this bro no it's not it's not about it's
it's a great question you're asking it's
not
toir out remember he's the guy that do
want him here so imagine I want you at
Val you're here cuz I want you you know
I believe in you you know I'm a fan of
yours matter of fact yesterday while
we're doing our meeting during lunch I
showed a video of you oh God when you
were the uh protest stripper protest
stripper I show that clip and I'm
sitting there saying we're cracking up
laughing we're watching clips of you
okay my kids watch clips of you not that
one but then no not that one but imagine
imagine if all of a sudden one guy with
in the organization hates you okay
inment and it's sabotaging and bringing
me stuff to say that you suck and you
had a meeting with him five years ago
and he's you for 45 minutes you're
standing there absolute disrespect
insult straight up doing that okay so
the company knows McAfee's a stud the
company knows McAfee can bring numbers
in but this guy doesn't and he wants to
sabotage your success you have beef with
him so so for Pat McAfee though here's
the issue guess what Pat why are you
surprised you chose to go to a Dei
organization you chose to go to an ESG
organization you chose to go to Disney
you chose to go to ESPN you knew you
were going to get this right you knew
this was going to happen to you this is
not going to happen at bar stool this is
not going to happen at Spotify this is
not going to happen if you're
independently kicking some ass but it is
going to happen if you choose to go to
an organization like that and by by the
way this will be just the beginning it's
not going to get any less okay do not
think for a moment they're not calling
them from the top saying well listen you
can't ever make a comment like that
about Jimmy Kimel and you better call
and apologize publicly you think Pat
McAfee did that cuz he didn't they
didn't call him and tell him you better
apologize to Jimmy kemel and Jimmy Kel
coming back you know the most viral
tweet of that week with 100 million
views of course you better believe but
you chose to go to it's like it's like
you right now choosing to take your
talent and going to not SNL no you
choosing to take your talent and go to
uh I'm trying to see pick one man you
not Fox News you're choosing to go to
MSNBC okay and you're going to but but
then and you're surprised that people
are backstabbing why are you surprised
you calling me saying you won't believe
how they're treating me Vinnie why are
you surprised yeah you went to MSNBC you
went to a place that they there's only
one way of thinking there can be debate
there can be discourse it's only their
way of thinking Tom look ESPN is dying
I'll say it again ESPN is dying they're
not in a growth mode they're in an
adjustment mode Bob Iger was walking
around at the Allen and Company
conference you know the earlier mean
last year where they all get together
media confab and he was unable to have
any strategic we're looking at strategic
Alternatives translated will somebody
please buy this off me right
that's what it's all about and the same
thing by the way the same thing happened
for zaz who was walking around you know
saying hey do you want to buy a copy
watch or CNN you know opening up his
this lapel to display it yeah come on so
here's what's happening bureaucrats like
this guy you know are getting points for
saving money at ESPN so everybody's
going to be trying to do it different
way everybody's trying to cut cost
somewhere someone thought it was a good
idea to bring him on and to bring
ratings and everything but guess what
what inside Corporate America these
aren't Founders these are people with
positions and they're freaking
bureaucrats and they're backstabbers and
they have individual tribes based on
departments and so you've got people
that want to save money for ESPN and get
brownie points with Uncle Bob Iger for
doing so and so they want to cut stuff
and they want to cut stuff that doesn't
resonate with their political Viewpoint
that's what's going on here you're
seeing this parlor game go on at ESPN
that's all it is that's what's happening
and
guess what Norby and all the rest of EX
your boss is trying to sell you well
here's the deal what I know about Pat
McAfee if that guy's wearing sleeves on
TV he means business yeah yeah cuz that
guy has never worn a sleeve on TV in the
history of his show all he wears is cut
off t-shirts or wife feeders okay that's
all he wears so I think he's trying to
step his game up I think he gave a shout
out to our buddy who was at the so house
party um that for dressing him up in
suits you know that guy but
Pat you played in the NFL you were a
sick punter welcome to the big leagues
buddy you know it's a different level
you're you're dealing with a lot of
different accountability and a lot of
different personalities when you go from
being just an independent podcast type
of place to go to ESPN right who owns
ESPN leag though but that's not the big
leagues you don't think ESPN is the big
league no it's not the big leagues not
anymore no no not to what's bigger
thanit wa wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait I don't know what the hell you're
saying you're saying he wasn't big
leagues and then he goes to ESPN and
ESPN is Big League bro they paid him $85
million kids he was a number one sports
show in the world correct he is the big
league okay he chose to go to the Little
League that's dying what are you talking
about the last thing he needed FYI
here's a question for you we fully
disagree on this here's a question for
here's a question for you who needs who
who needs oh ESPN needs him okay then so
who's the big league ESPN is no it's not
number one for sports still where stepen
a Smith host his show that is still the
big leag it might not be their longm
laid off 25 of their Top Talent last
year but wait a minute you you have to
realize like when you think most people
in America have never heard of Pat
McAfee before he came to ESP no that's
that's if you're a sports fan you did sh
most
americ the nobody how are you going to
convince me that ESPN is not the big
leagues I'm all yours go ahead Tom no no
no no wait a minute no no wait a minute
this is not you think you've made it
when you're at ESPN you think that's
what it is is that the interpretation
you have in your mind that you've made
it when you're at ESPN this guy made it
way before he was at ESPN this guy made
it at bar stool this guy made it with
his show with his podcast ESPN didn't
validate who Pat McAfee is zero this is
not the big leaks this is called you
chose to make take money from people
that will control you that's all that is
but you know that when you go into the
door you know that no but but but you
don't need them you don't need
ESPN so so for example when you're at a
when you're when you're somebody this is
not a teleprompter Guy this is not a guy
that I agree this is not a guy that is
going up to ESPN because he went to the
right journalist school and all this gu
was a freaking punter tackling people
loudmouth entertaining fun party guy
football pton Manning exactly he played
with a lot of studs and then all what
does he do he builds a show he gets big
ESPN is begging for him to go there cuz
they desperately need him it is not the
other way around you're not you're not
on a you're not joining an organization
that's coming off of backto back to back
to backto back championships and you're
going on the ride like hey I'm going to
ride Tom Brady's cotel to win a
championship uhuh ESPN is not that
organization you're going to a place
that's been coming off of losses after
losses after losses in the recent years
and you're joining them when when you
join an organization that's dying you're
going there because they're hoping you
save them you're not going because
they're hoping to save you it's the
other way around this guy's not going
there this isn't like a guy that had a
you know 20 year career running the
sports and then he's going to an
organization because they're going to be
like uh well you know come and play the
last two years you're going to be a
great locker room guy and you're going
to develop these younger guys that's
what we need from you right now now bro
I'm on my Prime I'm killing it I'm
number one in the world is who I am
that's Pat McAfee you on me pay up but
the mistake he made Pat which I think is
a big mistake he made he made a mistake
thinking whoever sold him that there's
not going to be you cannot have a Aaron
Rogers calling out a guy that forced the
entire country to take the vaccine or
else and the late night host taking
shots at him that's the mistake he made
he teamed up with the wrong organization
question yeah I want you to respond so
and if that's the case which I I agree
somebody has to go it ain't going to be
Pat mcae who's that other guy who's that
other guy that he just called out that
guy has to leave like he
can't say how does that guy stay on no
guys what are you guys like what did you
guys smoke this I'm saying are they get
we were hanging out with Elon Pat this
guy's this guy's not gonna he's not
going to be at ESPN for too long the guy
no no M mca's contract whatever it is
he'll write it out how long is it for
because here's what you have to ask
yourself okay all right so you ready all
right you're in a marriage yeah okay
you're married to somebody matter of
let's just say you're dating a girl okay
you've been together with her for 3
years you love her okay however she does
cocaine every day but you love her
mhm okay you ask her babe I love you I
want to marry you but you got to stop
with this cocaine thing she says if you
love me love me with the cocaine what
are you going to do one of two people
have to change okay either you have to
change and accept the fact that it's
okay with her doing cocaine for the rest
of your life of being with her because
you're crazy about her or she's got to
stop doing cocaine do you think she's
going to stop doing cocaine no she just
told you no okay in this situation you
know who's the cocaine girl ESPN yeah
ESPN is not going to stop doing cocaine
I understand the analogy and the
reference I'm making to you so either
mcafe is going to change or ESPN's going
to change who do you think is going to
change in this situation I have an
answer you know what my answer is
neither neither is going to change so
what does that leave
you mcafe is going to be out cuz ESPN's
culture is not going to change what are
we talking about Sage Steel do you want
me to go through a list of names where
is Chris brousard not there when's the
last time you saw Chris brousard he was
one of my where is Chris where is all
these where are a lot of these guys so
how many of these guys all of a sudden
disappear where why did they disappear
what do they all have in common just
because politically they were not
willing to just sit there and apologize
and kiss some ass and be BLM be part of
this be part of like dude I don't want
to do that you better take the vaccine I
don't want to do that get the hell out
yeah mcafe is not going to kneel this
environment unfortunately is not
conducive for a guy like Pat McAfee you
know why Joe Rogan was happy with
Spotify they had us back cuz they're
like we don't give a yeah do say
what you want do we don't give a we
don't give a but ESPN and Disney
gives a yeah they give way too many
they give a so there you have
it and when you see what they do Pat you
see what they say publicly and you see
what they leak remember the cont they're
trying to save costs they may regret
doing it for his his point of view and
for the fact that it's an $85 million
Albatross how many times have we seen a
professional sport it's like a bad deal
is done and two years after the bad deal
exhibit a Denver Broncos and Russell
Wilson they are trying to do anything
they can to get that Albatross off their
books this is the way it works they may
be looking at this and saying look he
hasn't blown up and doubled his ratings
he's not a super duper Cash Cow but he's
doing really well let's get him out of
here and what Norby may be doing is
leaking things because there may be a
ratings-based performance Clause that's
in the contract and if you could turn
down mcafe or you could actually
him a little bit you might be able to
get the contract off your books there
may be Escape Clauses in there Trust me
neither one of these guys are going to
want to be there long term it's like a
relationship you're in that you know is
not going to work out long term well
this is what happens when you take the
money and with all due respect to Pat
awesome guy awesome Talent you know we
talk about ESPN being the sinking ship
there's still the biggest ship on the on
the ocean that's without a doubt like if
you think of sports name the first uh
broadcast company when it's when
something's sinking it's sinking okay
but they're still the Titanic right we
all know that sunk correct and they died
yes but we all acknowledge that that was
the biggest ship ever and they going yes
okay and this is why they gave him an
ear sinking Size Doesn't Matter okay
well can I make my points no because
you're going to
die but this is what happens when you
follow the money do you know how much
money Pat McAfee made between 2009 and
2012 being a punter for the
Indianapolis Colts $1.8 million $450
over four years all right what's he
making from ESPN 85
million over five years he's making what
157 million made his show the guy made
his show his show the sickest show out
there yes yeah but then he said okay
this sick show that I made let me go
cash it in on ESPN if these
huckleberries want to pay me $85 million
you know what sign me up so you must
know when you go to ESPN who's owned by
ABC who's B by owned by Walt Disney
Corporation you're going to have some
accountability right there and of course
we bring up the Jimmy Kimel situation
which we can talk about the comedians
where does Jimmy Kimmel do his show ABC
you know what you're getting into when
you walk in the door I'm sorry now
granted I'll take the freaking money the
85 million but save me the crocodile
tears about oh my God I can't believe I
can't say what I want to say you know
that when you sign your $85 million deal
homie but but you you would take the
money I don't think Pat is the guy that
would take the money he took the money
Pat what do you mean
hear hear me out what I'm saying to you
no let me make my point what I mean by
Pat Pat took the money but Pat is
sitting there regretting saying it's not
worth the money it's not worth the money
for you to have to change yourself to uh
uh to what do you call it to all of a
like for example conform to this and
this watch what's happening with Forbes
okay a liberal company buys forbs and
starts flipping the content that fed
capitalists and doers and executives to
now some virtue signaling Dei
do I buy Forbes today no mhm so what
happens to them they're losing customers
because they're not talking to so if Pat
McAfee goes to Disney he has a big
following that likes his style and then
now he has to change his way that
garnered him all this foll and then his
drop viewership drops he's like oh
as a competitor what happened nothing
happened you just changed and your
audience doesn't like to new you because
because now you're the ESPN U the
audience like the old youu and ESPN and
Disney is not going to let McAfee just
be McAfee they're not going to do it can
you imagine if they tell him hey man
moving forward you cannot have any more
Aaron Rogers on your show y but say
you go for it go ahead and say it to
ESPN say to then resign exactly then
then then you know what if if it if it
takes you going from $450 a year to $17
million a year you're going to have to
make some concessions most people are
going make those concessions I'm sorry
no no what I'm saying is no no no no I
again we're going to find out meaning
we're going to find out if he's going to
make those concessions or not we're
going to see if p is going to be
somebody that's going to be like okay
I'll become this woke liberal person as
long as they P I don't think that he's
going to go that extreme not whatsoever
and that's why he's naming names it's
not like he's calling out ESPN it's not
like he's calling out his executive
producer he's calling out one person
Norby Williamson like in Seinfeld said
back in the day he named no he didn't
just say no okay go back to the clip Rob
go back to the clip he said one person
undering my show nope no go back to the
clip you played go back to the clip you
played he did not say one person he
named one name nope he did not just
mention one name listen to words okay
English is not my first language but
listen to what he says fast forward 30
seconds into it Go 30 keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
try it from right there let's see if
it's right there
of what our show is and then are we just
going to combat that from a rat every
single time I don't know but like
somebody tried to get ahead of our
actual ratings release with wrong
numbers 12 hours beforehand that's a
sabotage attempt and it's been happening
basically this entire season from some
people who didn't necessarily love the
old edition of the pat mcy show to the
usbn family sure there's a lot of those
there's a lot of those that's English to
me there is a lot of do
no no it's not he only said one name he
said there is a lot of those but he said
one name dbd he said he said No No No's
we played the clip he said one he's not
Adam he's not talking about one person
what he's saying is there's a lot of
those at ESPN I don't doubt it but he
only said one name of course he's going
to not get 50 names cuz the other names
you don't give a about that's the
biggest name but he named one no but he
said there is a lot of those English
their he didn't say their Nam rewinded
five seconds for this guy that had a 4.0
gpn in high school play the clip Mr 4.0
you're going to hear one name and I hate
arguing with about this pbdb I don't
have any hang on be quiet listen there's
a lot of those there's a lot of Play It
Again I can we play the beginning of the
goddamn CLI the beginning of the goddamn
clip please think we have to hear it one
more time the beginning of the clip go
forward go ahead buddy this what they do
on mainstream media sure there's a lot
of those there is a lot of my God it's
plural it's plural sorry Pat I got to
hijack the show play the clip from the
beginning Rob stop it he said one name
pbd you think I have Tom shut your one
thing move on one thing ESPN had 98
million subscribers now at 73 and
dropping un this time of year from now
the subscriber number will start with a
six this isensor and it's so good it's
so great ESPN is doing so well Disney's
trying to sell it to the first person
that'll buy it Tom stop brown noosing
pbd okay I'm not brown noosing he's
giving facts buddy it's fact fact okay
I'm going to read the article I have to
cuz you won't play the clip cuz you
don't want to prove me right play play
no no wait a minute prove you right what
you said he's only talking about one
person I said he only said one name no
the entire organiz it do you do you
realize what's your point though are you
saying like one name versus plural yes
you're saying only one person doesn't
like him there I'm saying there's
probably more but why did he single out
one person why do I even know this name
Norby Williamson right now you're right
now guy I've never heard of Adam are you
saying there is he didn't say that
there's more people at the organization
that don't like him I'm saying he did
say there's a reason that he said cor
okay there's a reason he said William
biggest head executive he's calling out
okay but there's a lot of people who
don't like him there and it's not a good
feeling when you go to work and you know
a lot of people don't like you and what
you stand for and that's not sustainable
long term for a person who is a freefor
all guy that has proven to the market
that he's the best at what he does okay
ahead of Stephen A they paid him more
than they pay Stephen a straight yes
Stephen A doesn't make this kind of
money they're about to give Stephen A
his contract Stephen A still only makes
$68 million per year okay $12 million
per year they pay McAfee more than they
pay Stephen A think about that so the
market is saying McAfee is better than
Stephen A getting Galls okay okay Steph
a is going to get paid though Stephen A
should get paid but I mean I have a
whole different opinion with that we're
not going to get into that okay let's go
next year which do we want to go Kim
story since we were already discussing
it you're talking about the late night
we only have 20 minutes and I don't want
to go let's I I will give three minutes
to the story and that's it and you got
only 30 seconds on this story I'm going
to come to you last okay I'm going to
the bathroom I'm in trouble right now
because I'm working because you go
you're you're ranting for 5 minutes and
we can't get to the next story no one
else does that Watch Dog finds 81% of
all iCal late night show jokes in 2023
targeted conservatives a study by media
Research Center found that 81% of all
political jokes on major late night
comedy shows in 2023 targeted
conservatives the study analyzed 9500
jokes political jokes from six major
late night shows revealing a significant
bias against right leaning subjects
amongst the analyzed shows Jimmy Kimel
live the highest rate of
anti-conservative jokes
88% of its 2 215 political jokes
damn targeting conservative Steven coar
show came in second with
86% out of his 1918 jokes followed by
Seth Meers at 84% from his 2445 jokes
all anti-conservative the Daily Show was
at 78% of its 1277 political jokes
targeting conservatives Jimmy Fallon
show had a more even split with
66% of its 1416 political jokes directed
at conservatives James Cordon shows
which ran for only four months in the
year had 54% of 245 jokes go ahead what
are your thoughts on this wonderful
story nobody shocked if you I haven't
listened to late night uh comedy in
Forever there's a reason that Greg
Gutfeld show who's the least funniest
comedian on TV is the number one late
night show there's a reason because when
you when you Pander to half the country
it's not a smart business move the
Vinnie you know this the whole point of
Comedy is misdirection you don't see it
coming okay when you're predictable and
everyone's like did you hear what Trump
did the other day it's a threat
democracy ha it's like we know it's
coming the whole point of misdirection
how many people come up to you and say
Vinnie that fight you you and Adam
almost got in bro you got me cuz they
actually thought we were going to fight
next thing you know we walk in with a
birthday birthday cake for pbd but if
you're just fighting Trump every night
and you're predictable you're no longer
funny they haven't been but my thing is
they haven't been funny to begin with at
least like David Letterman you know it
was back and it was force it was Jay
Leno everybody was fun they're obviously
bought and paid for it's a political
activist move all bro if you think about
it would you ever have thought that
these pieces of scum would be having
vaccine dances where they're like shove
this shove this experimental drug in you
and your kids and your family and it's
an agenda bro it's an agenda it's not
funny it's unwatchable and we're seeing
it like you said when you sign up for
this these guys all hang out with these
same Elites they're all hanging out with
I saw him in New York with Chuck Schumer
and all these guys look look how
embarrassing bro look how these are not
comedians by the way I'm tired of people
using that word Loosely he's not a
standup comedian he's a personality and
look at that shitty personality bro
bought and sold in soulless soulless
people that are trying to make America
laugh and by the that audience they pick
up Applause signs and they go hey laugh
at this you have to laugh at this what
do you think about this time I think
it's completely surprising and
regardless of how these comedians feel
they are playing to The Narrative of the
network that employs them and so that's
what I think this is completely
unsurprising America needs equal time
America wants equal time love or hate
Fox News it was providing equal Time
Rush limau one of the greatest
monologues of his program I remember
when he gave similar stats they're
saying this on this radio station
they're saying that on this radio
station saying this on this radio
station and now they want the hush rush
act on Capitol Hill I am equal time and
it was a bold statement but he was right
he says I am equal time you want equal
time because you don't like people
listening to me I'm outnumbered I am
equal time and I just it's this is
unsurprising to me and you know what I
got you here's what I would say just to
just to wrap up and transition is um
this is why you got to love data how
awesome is it that data reveals
everything you can get angry as much as
you want Mark cuin at data with Dei but
out of 21 Seasons when guardian wrote
the paper 15 of those 21 Seasons you led
the whitest team in the NBA and then the
last two years you owned the team until
you sold it so that means you know
whatever numbers you want to give it 75%
of the time you had the whitest team in
the NBA Mr Mark cubin claims Dei then
goes and hires a female black president
for the Dallas Mavericks just to kind of
uh virtue signal to the marketplace
numbers don't favor you I went into what
is that Gloria aled you know that lawyer
that's the the goat of sexual harass
girl I went and interviewed her in her
office and she starts saying are you a
bigot are you this are you that I said
how many of your employees here are uh
uh women well did you see my friend Des
clerk did you I said I looked at all
your partners on the wall they were all
men do you have any female Partners she
changes the subject data sucks yeah data
sucks data reveals everything data shows
good bad ugly okay when we sit there and
we're like dude V time I'm like Mario
we've had a this two or three times
we've done this Mario the last 100
videos we've done we're not getting
eyeballs okay we got to change the show
sucks right now this was a you know
three times we went through when we took
a break at you know 80,000 subs and at
450,000 subs and we took a break at a
month at a million Subs I'm like dude
I'm doing so many different things I'm
running so many different I just don't
have the bandw right now let's take a
three- Monon break we come back we
improve the show data never ever lies
data tells you the late night is all 50%
of America can't stand the late night
shows and they're just pandering to
Their audience it's what they're doing
and that's why you got to love data so
that's the best part about what I do
whatever these guys did good for them
for taking the time to pull up the stats
to see what's going on let's go to the
next by the way within that space with
comedy Joe Koy his monolock flops you
know what he says it was a tough crowd
no Joe it's not a tough crowd
you tried to please them you weren't a
comedian you were trying to kiss some
ass and you were afraid of giving jokes
and you know what happens when comedians
are owned by the audience and you show
Fear it's over you lose and it was felt
by everybody exactly there we have a
couple guys we wanted this guy to come
and perform at the event a couple years
ago eventually didn't work out we ended
up having a a a a mancal you know and
and what do you call it and we had Kevin
Hart we've had a bunch of different
people that have come
but Matt saalo is a big fan of Joe Koy
okay he says he he likes Joe Koy great
cuz he's Filipino cuz he Filipino no
problem but you know what you saw when
you saw the monologue you were trying to
Pander to them you were trying to make
sure everybody liked you you walked on
eggshells Ricky Jes came in and said I
don't give a if you want to be my
friend or not and he got hundreds of
millions of views the most viral
monologue ever so if you're a comedian
and you want to know why the most viewed
interview of all here on YouTube maybe
of the last 12 months is a guy named Cat
Williams cuz cat came and dropped the
bomb on Shay Club Shay podcast with
Shannon sharp can you go to the podcast
to see how many views Cat Williams got
go to cat william5 million I don't know
how many of you it's a 2our and 46
Minute Podcast of which you watched
twice tce just go to YouTube and see how
many you no I just want to see how many
views it's got what's the number right
now two wait that's a short that's a
short go to uh
that I'm telling you it's like over 30
million 37
million 37 million views in five days
you know why but but by the way you know
why though cuz cat didn't give a
and if you're at a you're a comedian
you're going up there trying to please
the world you get the kind of ratings
that you get uh and joy first of all I
mean Joe Joe Koy amazing human being a
really good friend I I'm curious do you
think it because of what Ricky Jes did
Pat like on everybody now they have
to see everything that you joke they
want to know all your jokes and all your
stuff and you have did that to him if
they did that to him you're not a
comedian I got so you're saying he
should have just been like no I'm not
going to do it if they did that to him
you're not a comedian wow if they did
that to you I don't see you as a
comedian I see you as a host not a
comedian you're a host if you're worried
like when when uh what's his name got up
there and and uh pton Manning is a
better comedian at esps than Joe Koy
Payton's Manning's monologue was 10
times better than Joe ky's monologue
pton Manning got up and said you know
the women's swim team or soccer team is
doing so good right now that Kevin
Durant is asking for
trade that's yeah he doesn't give a
yeah and you're like oh and then he
going to the next person and the next
person and the next person that's a
comedian yeah but Joe Coy was afraid to
make people feel uncomfortable even the
joke he took the shot he took at Taylor
Swift he was hesitant about it you just
don't do that as a comedian go go for it
and light it up next story all right so
here here's what we're going to next the
santis some politics story here for you
is the santis going to drop out of the
race on January 15th okay this is the
hill page
10 all right let's see what's going to
happen here so two well-informed sources
within the the santis campaign suggest
that the governor if the governor loses
Iowa caucus to former president Donald
Trump on January 15 he might drop out of
the race that night or make his
announcement the next morning despite
campaign denials furthermore these these
sources speculate that the santis may
very begrudgingly endorse Trump for
president following a trend of
Republican politicians supporting the
clear front runner as evidenced by
recent endorsement from from House
Majority with Tom emmer Majority Leader
Steve scal and speaker Mike Johnson Des
Santa's declining poll numbers coupled
with the potential for more endorsements
and financial support for Trump after
Iowa could significantly impact his
decision Adam well look here's my
message to Ron
STIs look I think it's time for a reboot
you got to get out there and you know
you got to get some boots on the ground
you got to get out there and you got to
get your people out there I know that he
sort of bootstrapped his campaign and he
basically he got lobbyists out there
doing his thing uh but at this point
Trump is not shaking in his boots and
unless he gives some sort of uplifting
message and gets Trump back on his heels
nothing's going to change here for Ronda
santz so unfortunately
going do unfortunately I think Trump is
going to take his boots and he's going
to walk all right all over you so that's
my message for Ronda santis I think it's
I detect a theme here from Adam you know
it's uh Boots are Made for Walking Tom I
shot to sketch yesterday B him by the
way look there's there there's two
things happening in every election the
closer you get to the real election
those who are unable to um Step Up uh
stand taller and mount a challenge um
back off and usually
break all party lines and support the
front runner that's usually what happens
and it appears to be that the leaks are
coming out we've tried we've done all
this but if we really get a whooping and
there's no path to go forward maybe win
the next state which is you know the New
Hampshire and South Carolina and all
that and get into Super Tuesday then the
question is comes from everybody
including the RNC Good Friend R um what
are we doing with this money are we just
going to burn this money trying to fight
each other are we going to get behind
somebody and go win a main election I
think that's what's happening and also
isn't it interesting yes that after
standing on the sidelines Washington's
major groups are breaking for Trump
because these aren't just random guys
House Majority Whip Tom emmer Majority
Leader Steve
scales speaker Mike Johnson this isn't
like three guys from Colorado said hey
Trump we've always been with you always
here the major sections of the party and
its leadership are moving toward the
reality of the polls and Trump and this
is swinging this is swinging on a
Supreme Court decision with the
arguments February 8th and you're
getting a decision out of that probably
two weeks lat things are obviously
things are starting to heat up I Tom
what's that word right there
begrudgingly what does that mean he
DeSantis may very begrudgingly not happy
to do so it go goes like this if you
want the car keys got your date this
weekend you will walk in and apologize
to your sister so you begrudgingly go
into your sister and say I'm sorry so
which which would be interesting because
I mean we talked about this way back
when when this all started would if he
drops out would Trump consider having
this guy as a vice president which I
think he should have done from the
beginning not run but then this all
leads into everything that's heating up
everything that's happening right now
Tom like especially with with uh Barack
Obama did you guys see this he's
starting to panic as well the the
article Washington Post said that he
grew animated we all know that means
he's probably cussing and throwing a
tantrum in discussing the 2024 election
with former president Donald Trump's
potential return to power he raised
questions about the structure of Biden's
re-election campaign he discussed the
matter directly with Biden and told him
that uh his his AIDS and allies of the
campaign need to be empowered to make
decisions without clearing them with the
White House this is a Washington Post
did you translate that you translate
that as Obama talked to Biden Biden want
to take his viice and then Obama's
proxies leak the story a th% and then
apparently they had a private lunch
which I'm pretty sure you know Joe Biden
had no idea what where the hell they
were what they were eating I goes I'm
pretty sure the lunch was hey this is
Obama hey Biden you're done you're going
to have to move over eat some of your
ice cream and guess what we're going to
have to make a change and I think you
know what that change is going to be
Roger Stone predicted it with us almost
two years ago Michelle Obama Michelle
Obama was on J shed's podcast have that
yesterday and you know what just to give
you guys a little thing she said she is
Patrick this is really scary and sad she
has kept awake at night M yeah take it
easy but the upcoming election and she
said I am terrified at what could happen
so and guess what she's going to run to
save democracy guys everybody this is
the warning this is her pre-presidential
I'm going to have to save America run go
ahead Rob things that keep me up because
you you don't have control over them and
you wonder where are people where are we
in this you know where are our hearts
what's going to happen in this next
election I am terrified about what could
possibly happen hands are because our
leaders matter who we select who speaks
for us who holds that bullied Pulpit
bully it affects us in ways that
sometimes I think people take for
granted so notice the timing notice the
timing right uh Biden having a meeting
with Obama Obama's panicking and then
she does this it's all a set plan and
cuz I'm telling you I'm warning you guys
the Gavin Nome Michelle Obama presidi is
scary as and by the way good old
gav what have you heard from Gavin in
two week no guess where he is you guys
don't know he's with Bill Clinton in
Mexico they were just spotted together
in Mexico guys it's we're heating up
what are the chances you think she runs
now great question I want to know what
are the Vegas odds right now cuz we did
I want to know your odds my odds of her
running yeah yeah
75% okay what do you think Adam who I'm
being genuine who do you think the left
is have how about this you want to have
a little fun well we already have a bet
let's see if she moved up U Michelle
Michelle moved to 25 and one Kennedy I I
don't believe well by the way of him
winning that's this is not a great this
is not a great B what we already have a
bet what's our bet um we have a bet
whether Trump is going to go Onan
podcast how much is the BET 500 the
election so you want put another 500
that Michelle Obama runs um I won't do
I'm I'm at 75% he say yes so you what do
you mean that means I'm at 25% you have
the odds I say I don't think she's
running are you going to give me odds
are you going to give me like three to
one for it's a $500 bet bro what are you
doing you can't even do the math you got
to take four to one uh number yeah four
to one I'll take cuz why am I going to
go straight to 4 yeah look look at this
look at this 25 to1 why am I going to
just bet straight up when the Vegas ODS
give me four to you just said 25% no if
you give me four to five how about this
we'll do a $500 bet okay if Michelle
runs Starbucks I give you
$1,000 if she does not run you just give
me 500 no that's not by the way this is
a 25 I'm not going by the way while you
guys are going back you guys can talk
about this afterwards what I can tell
you is Michelle's 25 to1 Newsome's 10
to1 yeah so what this telling you right
now if they do anything nome's the one
that they have on this list okay if they
do anything Newsome is the one that they
have as a favorite to do that and by the
way while you're going through the story
let me kind of go into this next story
yes sir Biden will pull out of the
presidential race according to JP Morgan
not not anybody this is JP Morgan saying
strategist Michael sist predicts he's a
strategist at JP Morgan that President
Joe Biden will withdraw from 2024
presidential IAL election race between
super Tuesday and November due to his
low approval rating of 37% compared to
Donald Trump's
59% in terms of handling the economy as
well as concerns about his age with 71%
of posters considering him too old
Michael the strategist foresees a
significant boycott of driverless cars
especially following safety issues uh
Rob what does that story have to do with
this the second part he's making
predictions oh I and I have the got a
couple he's saying that the presidency
is a
driverless no but by the way this number
is not a small number here and this is
not like a regular guyp Morgan he's and
I and I have and I he compiled the list
they're called the 10 surprises of 2024
uh and one of them is the our dollar and
the war in Ukraine so he theorize Biden
would drop out like you said Pat super
Tuesday and then this what else he said
he said the US dollar remains stable
the doj and FTC win a big antitrust case
President Biden withdrawals from
November the driverless car backlash is
coming broadly syndicated loan losses
rise above private credit losses for the
first time Tom Argentine
dollarization Argentine dollarization
will fail if implemented Russia invasion
of Ukraine drags on with no ceasefire in
2024 that's a prediction yeah yeah no
uh despite storm clouds over us
Regional Banks their stock will do well
uh due to retirement of dispatchable
power here we go this is Leave the World
Behind major cities will face
electricity outages Andor natural gas
outages outages oh and last thing are
you ready for this Rob I know you're
going to love this one because you're
probably waiting in line you're on back
order researchers will complete work on
an inhaled covid vaccine so now if you
want poison you could just just the hell
with getting a needle now you can just
suck it in your face going back to it
all JP Morgan is saying is what what is
the obvious and what I I'm on the same
page as Roger Stone and many other
people it's not like Roger and I are in
an island together in this opinion the
delicate hopefully not that
Island you just I don't know I would not
even refer the island never use the word
Island again he says going broke a book
by who did you say no I don't know what
you're talking about Pat and then you
saying Island censorship so it's anyway
go ahead Tom so it's the anyway back to
that Island you're hanging out with ro
go the super delegate rules are very
clear the Democrats can change their
allegiance at the convention they will
do so thank you for playing here's your
Lifetime Achievement Award and we are
voting in someone else which is also why
they're not doing a primary that's when
I'll give I'll give you a 10 second I'll
give you 10 seconds ju wait wait when is
when is July July is six months right
but super Tuesdays in March yeah but I
super Tuesday doesn't matter there's not
going to be a super Tuesday in the in
the Democrat Party they're not they're
not doing primary ask you guys before so
we are six months six months from we
should cover it live pbd we should have
a live coverage of the first night of
voting of the DNC because what's going
to happen the superdelegates are going
to come out they're going to do this and
there it is and then we're going to see
who they vote for and right now 10 to1
says Nome what percentage do you give
Michelle Obama you and Patrick if you
had to just a percentage right now if
you just have to guess where you at I I
think nome's our guy and they've been
trying to make look good for foreign
policy and a lot of other things what
about Michelle maybe but I I think news
are no percentage you don't have a a
guest give me a gu% I I think I I would
say it's probably 70 maybe 30 Nome
Michelle I'm at 10% 10% that she does
run she has she has to save democracy
she can't sleep and that you don't care
about her an interview it's just an
interview with J sh it's not it's not a
campaign announcement the we're giving a
little too much credibility to this guy
I know he's smart Michael sest you've
never heard of him today no I'm saying
I'm talking about you've never heard
about this guy before today the title of
this article should be should have been
smart guy makes predictions this ain't
JP Morgan this ain't this ain't no
strategist it's just a smart guy making
10 predictions now do I think he could
be right on some stuff do I think he
could be wrong on some stuff sure but
let's not like the other guy that just
the other guy I forget his name but Pat
you remember his name he's like the
economy 90% recession Harry Dent yeah
you Harry dent
Jimmy har yeah where of you all there
you exactly sounds like a bad guy
in a Batman sorry I cussed anyway I got
to go do an appearance on the patmac if
you show guys after this so talk to you
guys later man oh man all right so there
you have it guys uh a lots of a lot of
crazy stuff that we we just talked about
here by the way one last thank you Rob
if you want to pull it up man's been on
fire last week I am responding a 100% of
audio on man we have a contest that
we're running and I want to publicly
announce this contest and you get to
support whoever you want to help win
first I told Tom Vinnie and Adam this
was about what two weeks ago when was
this contest two or three weeks aspect I
ran a contest for them I said whoever
gets 500 mans from that day that we had
Tom can you pull up the number to see
where I think Tom you have the lead then
I think it's Adam then it's Vinnie it's
still ear I think I said whoever gets
500 mans from that day wins a $22,000
suit custom whatever you want will go to
the store I'm going to pick up a brand
spanking new suit for you so if you love
Adam if you love Vinnie if you love Tom
whoever you love the most man with them
pleas download the app send a message to
Vinnie he will respond back in audio or
video or you can have a 15-minute call
with him or you can ask Tom questions
about business and other things you want
to do Tom's blowing up with manck a lot
I think Tom's only $23 a man where you
at right now for man for for a text for
text he's like $15 and then Adam where
you at you're also at uh uh I don't
think 25 bucks 25 bucks I'm the cheapest
come to me f just so everybody knows no
one's gotten more mans than Adam so far
Adam's the only one above 600 man so
whoever you want to talk to he's the
goat man right now send a message to
them and Tom actually just passed top G
I told Andrew T just so you know Tom
just passed you up and we called time to
top te top yday more than anything I
know that this is a little contest
between
us how rewarding is it talking to all
these guys out there and gal it's so
cool we really enjoy talking to you a
lot whether you're starting bu changing
conversations changing whether you're
starting a business whether you're
having relationship problems whether
you're literally having depression
whether you're trying to figure out what
you're trying to do in your career I
know that we have a little contest of
who can help the most people but let's
not forget that we're actually helping
people process it's like business
therapy and it's actually super the same
time whoever you want to see win the
suit support them the
most time or Adam take care everybody
we'll do the is it tomorrow we're doing
Thursday right Thursday we got podcast
again take care everybody bye- bye
bye-bye